[Music]  62% of our planet is in the midst of a  catastrophic drought countless people  have either died or been displaced  because of it our technology is giving  these people a chance  my partner let's go return  I'm looking for answers drones those  things are evil you know go come to  anyone I've got a drone  these new Sentinel drones are developed  with the Department of Defense to  monitor forward operating bases in  hostile environments reconnaissance and  submission submission John was on to  know  and now Vasco is trying to destroy  anybody that's all into the story you  can make it as rain you know the plan  we need to get out of here  [Music]  a world just whole lot brighter  [Applause]  you